[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
hey what is up guys i'm pbhd here and
welcome to the first q a of 2019. now
you may notice or you may look back and
see that i didn't do the monthly q a for
december of last year or november i
think maybe like six of you noticed but
real talk i want to focus more on more
meaningful videos this year in 2019 and
i feel like at the end of those months
it started to feel kind of forced like
we would be doing a monthly q a but
there wasn't a whole lot more extra to
talk about so i'm leaning more this year
towards doing more more topical and more
analytical videos instead of slipping
those things into q and a's if people
asked about it if that makes sense so
that being said we are about to head out
to ces but i figured before we get on
that plane might as well ask which one
to know on twitter and these are some of
your best questions alright so shafiq uh
wanted to know why was the mate 20 pro
on the table next to the iphone in the
most recent post on instagram so that
top down shot of what i'm bringing to
ces was actually shot a couple weeks ago
as part of a collab with the verge so a
lot of you guys may have seen that
recent community post but theverge.com
they've done this what's in my bag
series with a long history of really
interesting guests and things like that
and they asked if i wanted to do one i
said guys i've already done one and a
lot of them have seen that already but
if you want to see what's in my video
bag right before ces that could be cool
so we shot that a couple weeks ago it's
on our channel i'll link it below if you
want to watch it
but at that time when we shot that i was
reviewing the mate 20 pro so that's why
it was in my bag now as far as phones
i'm currently using bring the ces this
is the mclaren edition oneplus 6t in all
its shiny and
glossy glory
it's my current daily and i have the
iphone 10s max of course as my daily
iphone but you know i carry two and i
think that's what i'm going to bring to
ces i'm kind of torn on i want to bring
the pixel because i know that's the best
camera that's the camera i can count on
for taking the best shots but i've been
having some bugs with it again recently
i might make a whole video on that if it
gets bad enough but it was enough to get
me to switch back to the oneplus 6t
every day so i think that's what i'll
end up with at ces but uh oneplus 6t
mclaren edition iphone 10s max space
gray all right anthony asks what fitness
and recovery tech are you using to train
for ultimate frisbee
and honestly
my time playing frisbee has actually
usually been also my time away from tech
usually on the weekends usually at
nights when there's practices and things
like that that's my time to not have
tech now lately i've been wearing the
apple watch a lot and getting into the
whole competitions thing which is a
seven day long who can get the most
points and close their rings the most
sort of competition in order to not lose
out on thousands of points i've been
wearing the apple watch while i play so
that's why sometimes i close my rings a
hilarious amount of times in 24 hours
but other than that i really don't use
that much tech or or fitness recovery
related tech for ultimate that's my time
away from it maria says are you going to
make an auto focus video on the porsche
takan yeah i hope to yes and like i've
talked about competitors to tesla before
but i think as far as direct competitors
to tesla model s especially the p100d
that i love so much the porsche
mission e is i think what they're going
to call it might be the closest
competitor as far as design everyone
loves porsche interior and the
superchargers are working on so yes i do
hope if anyone from porsche is watching
this i do hope to be able to actually
get a chance to check out the mission e
and compare it against the tesla all
right brianna asks will you start a
podcast this year and what will it be
brianna asks will you see
all right brie asks will you start a
podcast this year and what would it be
about
that might be referencing one of my
early year 2019 tweets
just sort of brainstorming that i should
start a podcast
ah now this idea kind of stemmed from
two things one i've been listening to a
lot more podcasts lately especially
while driving i've listened to so many
hours of music usually but i've been
getting into podcasts and two there are
just topics that you can only dive so
deep into before a video gets
excessively like in the weeds or too
long and there are things that i'd like
to talk about more or get into and
research and interview about more that
could be an hour long that i can't
really get into in a 10 15 minute video
and it's actually funny a lot of the
videos have slowly i don't know if
you've noticed but progressively gotten
a little longer on average over like the
last year or two we kind of average now
like 12 to 14 minutes um but that still
doesn't quite cover how much we could
talk about something so i like the idea
of a podcast but i don't want to just
jump right directly in and rush it like
i feel like i could just grab a mic and
just talk for an hour and upload it
right now and that's episode one but i
want to do it right so i want to sit
back we want to get a good name we want
to get a good scheme a good format and
start to put things together so i'll say
we're going to do something we're going
to do a podcast but look out for that
over the next couple weeks and months as
we start to set that up and we'll get
you guys feedback as we go along you'll
probably have ideas for how to make it
better just like the videos all right
what would you want to see in the tesla
model y that says 69 likes that's funny
so the the model y has been teased for
probably some 2019 unveiling and that
would be the suv that is the model 3 of
the suv world so i guess you could kind
of expect a lot of things from the model
3. you expect it to kind of look like a
tesla but pretty minimal on the inside
geared for autonomous driving like the
model 3
probably one screen in the middle
probably a lower price than the model x
those things are all pretty much
expected i honestly don't think we'll
see that many surprises with model y i
mean the design is the one thing we
don't know what exactly it'll look like
but then past that you know it's an suv
suvs are very popular i've been driving
an acura suv courtesy of acura thanks to
them since my car has been in the shop
and when you drive one you notice there
are a lot of other suvs on the road
especially in america so it makes sense
i kind of lowkey think model y might be
more important to tesla than model 3
just because of pure volume and just
getting that that size of the market um
but yeah i think it'll be very similar
to the model 3 we all know matthew
waller just says how many roadsters
though i don't know exactly what it
means by this but i do have an
interesting update to share so if you
remember way back at the beginning of
2018 i did a q a with austin where we
were talking
we were actually at tesla hq doing a
video
and i mentioned that if enough people
used my referral code
to buy it as some other tesla model s
model x then
i would get two percent off per person
for a tesla roadster 2020. well in that
last quarter of the year as tesla was
breaking all their own records and
shipping more cars than they ever have a
lot of people were ordering to try to
get their tax rebates in a lot of people
use my referral code and now it
currently sits at it says 100
progress to roadster 100
so
that's pretty incredible that basically
means
that enough of you 55 of you use the
referral code to equal 100 off
the roadster a free roadster but
basically there's still a lot we don't
know about this program well everyone
who's done this have to pay taxes income
taxes or capital gains tax on that
roadster which is just a massive
percentage of it there's a lot of
questions that still remain but i just
want to say thanks to everyone who's
used my referral code who has actually
gotten their car i hope you love it in
the past couple weeks and months um
because that's what's turned into 100
progress on this this program hopefully
it gets actually released on time all
right how's your tesla p100d surgery uh
on apollo has been so far a success i've
been tweeting and sharing occasional
updates on twitter and i'm sort of
keeping a timeline as things go on it's
at a body shop it's getting repaired
it's not totaled and it will be back now
if you remember the original photos the
damage was obviously more than skin deep
so there's gonna have to be parts that
are replaced uh luckily the body shop
that it's gone to which is in new york
has had most if not all the parts
actually already in stock which is
incredible so they you know they take
the doors off they take the sides off
they sort of inspect everything and they
start to go through that process of
replacing the parts that need to be
fixed they've already done the
suspension they've they've done the
doors they're doing a lot of the
cosmetic stuff now they obviously have
to re-wrap the doors the same color that
the car was wrapped but they've made a
lot of progress so hopefully maybe by
the time i get back from ces they'll be
almost done uh concious says you got
hardened for mvp this year
uh
i just want you guys to hear the the
drilling that starts up whenever i turn
a microphone on
i just can't i can't get a silent moment
so i just want to let you just listen to
this with me
all right so concious says you got
hardened for mvp this year uh i'm gonna
go with yes can we see you wearing your
glasses actually jeff so a lot of people
don't know this but from that what's in
my bag video with the verge i had my
contact lenses a lot of people were like
whoa you wear contacts do you have
glasses i actually don't own a pair of
glasses anymore i lost my original pair
from high school
that i did my first videos in so if
you'd want to see me in glasses you have
to go all the way back to those nine 10
year old videos but i actually since
then have not bought another pair of
glasses i've worn contacts for like nine
years
and just stopped worrying about glasses
i also tweeted i would like to probably
get lasik or something in the next
couple years maybe to see 2020 by 2020.
why is this drilling so loud it's
ruining my
20 20 puns bottom line yes you can see
me in glasses but it will be it will be
nine year old footage actually if you
want to see me in glasses i'll link
below again that commercial that i
should
if you want to see me in glasses more
recently you can look back at that
commercial i did with under armour and
steph curry in 2018 those were just like
fake prop glasses for me to appear more
as a nerd they don't even have lenses
for reflections but that's what i would
look like in glasses anyway canopsy
wants to know what's one thing you don't
want to see at ces 2019 and actually the
first response is
a bluetooth hair comb that's not that
far off i think maybe the best
worst tech that i see on a regular basis
especially at ces
is the adding internet to things
that
don't need internet or just adding the
word smart before something like smart
comb
you know or a smart toothbrush i don't
need a smart toothbrush but it
definitely exists
i already know what i'm going to see at
ces it's going to be a lot of pixels you
know all the tvs always show up more 8k
tvs than ever probably
and there's probably going to be a lot
of ai a lot of smart things
that's so loud
i get far enough away from the
microphone they'll probably stop ready
anyway
anyway
that's
that's uh
that's that's where i'm gonna end it
okay yeah now i'm just i'm just gonna
cut it there because i think that's all
the time we're gonna get between the
drilling thank you for your questions on
twitter i hope to see you guys a lot at
ces i know there's a lot of people
heading out to vegas in the next day or
two i'm about to get on a plane about to
drop this imac in the bottom of the
plane with me and hopefully we'll get
some good stuff out of the next couple
days either way i hope your
notifications are on so you get videos
during the wave of stuff that goes
through your sub box
that's about all i got to say thanks for
watching talk to you guys the next one
peace